[Music]
welcome back everybody 2020 this mostly
wretched year
is finally coming to a close thank god
it has been brutal for most americans
except maybe the media which had fun
torturing president trump and his
supporters let's remember some of our
favorite media meltdowns
from a year we'd all like to forget i'll
start with myself and how i was skewered
for suggesting we named the vaccine
after president trump the architect of
the vaccine
take a look geraldo may be on to
something
what trump stakes did for the hungry
what trump water did for the thirsty in
our nation
what trump university did to lift up the
uneducated in our country
well along comes trump the vaccine
geraldo really
come on bruh
come on don i think it's a great idea
anyway all right greg what's your
favorite you needed a name it should
have been called the trump shot
the trump shot not the trump vaccine and
it would have caught on all right
so you want to see how shallow how
shallow
the intelligence of the media is the
fact that what i'm going to show you
it's not just brian williams who's an
idiot or the reporter
it's that this information their entire
staff saw
and still thought this is this made
sense to them
look at this bloomberg spent 500 million
on ads
u.s population 327 million uh don't tell
us if you're ahead of us on the math he
could have given each american
one million dollars and have had lunch
money left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
yeah you should have played the whole
thing because the reporter goes
that's absolutely true they would all
get a million dollars
so that just i mean if you ever for a
minute think that people in the media
are smarter than you
they're not
good one but they get one dollar i mean
you got to give the punchline
yeah oh i'm sorry uh jesse your
television
mine is during the summer when
msnbc got on television and called the
protests mostly peaceful while fire was
engulfing them in the background watch
i want to be clear in how i characterize
this this is a
mostly a protest it is not
it is not generally speaking unruly but
fires have been started
so this was the baghdad bob moment where
they basically put propaganda above
people's safety because usually you can
push fake news in the dark
because it's anonymous sources or you
collusion this is like you're seeing it
with your own eyes and hearing it with
your ears
and they're saying don't trust your
senses trust me on msnbc
and every american saw that and then
went and bought guns and fled the cities
yes and dana what's yours it's like
it's like when you're watching a scary
movie and you're like behind you
um look behind you don't go i was gonna
do something about
i was gonna do something about
impeachment but there was just
i couldn't find like a perfect moment so
i chose my second favorite moment this
is
when chris cuomo who had coronavirus and
we're glad he got through it and he
documented the whole thing
so he does this very dramatic emerging
from the basement video i think that we
have this here take a look
the official re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc a little sweaty just
worked out happens
so um you know the the academy awards
should have gone to him for best actor
because he'd already left the house he
got in a fight with somebody on a bike
and it was all staged that's pretty
ridiculous
and katie
mine is about how the media freaked out
when president trump banned
travel from china and then they worried
so much about him calling it the china
virus that they were focused on that
instead of the details of how to fight
it
the president referred to the
coronavirus as a quote foreign virus
i think it's going to smack it's going
to come across to a lot of americans as
smacking of
xenophobia to use that kind of term in
this speech president also called this
a foreign virus what has he accomplished
by making this an outsider's problem
don't you think that this is a good time
for him to resign
congratulations everybody you just took
the communist chinese party's
talking points and threw them all over
american airwaves for months and then
accused republicans and the president
of not taking the virus seriously so
congratulations to them on that
on a great 2020